when you complete something like that
you ever sit back and go yo I cannot
believe oh we just did that I can't even
just made that I'm gonna be real with
you I listen to my and I am so proud I
don't care if anyone likes it this way
I'm so I have never been this excited
about anything ever in my career
[Music]
it's a bowl title yes it is so why why I
figured it out
yeah I'm away ahead of y'all ha ha
no I it was honestly the first other
than the fact that it was the very first
song we recorded for this album
[Music]
the track blew me away from right off
the bat had it for like three years and
other than that simple fact I just
thought man that's such a great title
cuz it's so poignant for my life right
now like I mean just once I hit 30 my
whole life changed I just was happier my
shoulders relaxed like I just I did I
didn't I always I feel like I worried so
much about keeping everything afloat for
everybody and I rarely like focused on
myself
so it was a really relaxing thing to
turn 30 and then everything from then
it's just been awesome you're out with a
new album so you're gonna be promoting
it a lot yeah obviously to perform all
your songs you want to perform - yeah
but how do you balance being a mom as
well I mean 1/3 is a very young yes it
is and they don't understand work like
they don't understand they're just like
so like defeated that you'd rather go
somewhere else than be with them which
gives mothers the guilty's I figured out
but my husband is like you're fine why
cuz he has a 10 and 16 year old - that's
our other - so he's already been through
it but like it's very hard I mean I'm
not gonna lie cuz you you know I miss
out a lot of cool things that happen but
I try and make them all you know and we
try and weave it in it's one reason why
I love sending with Atlantic Records
because Julie is a mom and she runs
Laennec and so it's nice and I told her
in the beginning like I am a workhorse
but I want you know my kids are first
and foremost I you know hasn't obviously
both professionals I've been working in
this industry for a long time does he
have how much input I should say does he
have into the songs that you write or
don't you choose for album my husband
has no filter I hope you're like yeah
that's not good he will walk right into
my my closet it's like a big closet so
it's like I had my office in their own
point and I'd like write to me like hey
baby baby I wrote this like come in and
sometimes he's like oh my gosh this is
awesome like and then other times it's
just straight up like pass was like no I
talked to my husband and my sister
really have no filter I don't either but
it's very helpful to have people are
you that you know aren't yes people so
but he definitely you know he has an
opinion which is great he should he's my
manager
you got a work for that money that's
right
you got a work for it